you know I have to say I was just a
couple of days ago I was working on this
uh chat gbt plug-in kit that we have for
awesome language okay where you can you
know you can create a plugin and it runs
with language code
um and it can run more from language
code back on your own computer yeah and
I was thinking well I can just make it
you know I can tell chat gbt create a
piece of code and then just run it on my
computer and I'm like you know that that
sort of personalizes for me the what
could what could possibly go wrong so to
speak was that exciting or scary that
possibility
it was a little bit scary actually
because it's kind of like like I realize
I'm I'm delegating to the AI just write
a piece of code you know you're in
charge write a piece of code run it on
my computer
and pretty soon all my files exactly
that's like a uh that's like Russian
Roulette but like much more complicated
yeah yes yes right that's a good
drinking game I don't know so well uh
right I mean
that's it's an interesting question then
if you do that right what is the
sandboxing that you should have and
that's sort of a that's a a version of
of that question for the world that is
as soon as you put the AIS in charge of
things you know how much how many
constraints should there be on these
systems before you put the AIS in charge
of all the weapons and all these you
know all these different kinds of
systems well here's the fun part about
sandboxes is uh the AI knows about them
it has the tools to uh crack them look
the fundamental problem of computer
security is computational irreducibility
yes because the fact is any sandbox is
never any you know it's never going to
be a perfect sandbox if you want the
system to be able to do interesting
things I mean this this is the problem
that's happened the generic problem of
computer security but as soon as you
have your you know firewall that is
sophisticated enough to be a universal
computer that means it can do anything
and so long as if you find a way to poke
it so that you actually get it to do
that Universal computation thing that's
the way you kind of crawl around and get
her to do the thing that it wasn't
intended to do and that's sort of a an
another version of computational
irreducibility is you can you know you
can kind of you get it to do the thing
you didn't expect it to do so to speak
there's so many interesting
possibilities here that manifest
themselves from the compute
computationally reducibility here
it's just so many things could happen
because in digital space things move so
quickly you can have a chat bot you can
have a piece of code that
you could basically have charged
generated viruses I said earlier on
purpose and they the digital viruses yes
and uh they could be brain viruses too
do they they convince kind of like uh
phishing emails yes they can convince
you of stuff yes and no doubt you can
you know in a sense we've had the loop
of the machine learning Loop of making
things that convince people of things is
surely going to get easier to do yeah
and you know then what does that look
like well it's again you know we humans
are you know we're this is a new
environment for us and admittedly it's
an environment which a little bit
scarily is is changing much more rapidly
than I mean you know people worry about
you know climate change is going to
happen over hundreds of years and you
know the environment is changing but the
environment for you know in the the kind
of digital environment might change in
in six months